uh let's see why don't we speak next
to oh i don't know
there's really just it's it's really a
uh it's
it's hard to pick because there's so
many great people holding
how about ryan from el paso texas
ryan you're on the air
uh hey david can you hear me all right
yes i can but uh discord is blinging in
the background that's the only issue
give me one second please okay
um so uh i'm i'm but i'm a bit of a
younger folk um
i'm a 13 years old and i was just
wondering
how i could get a little more
politically involved you know
because most people don't really uh like
you're just the kid you don't really
understand and i would just
you know like how i could sort of just
get myself out there
beautiful this is a great question
getting involved at your age is a
amazing thing to do so my
guess is most things you can't run for
right now because you probably need to
be 18 but that doesn't mean you can't
help out on a campaign so what i would
say is
maybe starting right in el paso um is
there
i don't know what the form system of
government there is but is there a
mayoral candidate you can help
is there a city council candidate that
you can help what about what's going on
in school board presumably you're going
to be in school for some
some years what about figuring out who
would you like to work with for school
board is there
school government that you could maybe
get involved in there's
really a lot of options it's just a
matter of knowing where to look
also by the way a lot of non-profits
that you could volunteer for at age 13
you might need a you know a parent
permission or something like that
um a lot of non-profits are working on
political issues so like if your
political issue you care about is
education or homelessness or whatever
you can probably find a non-profit to
volunteer with that would work
on that issue so there's really no
shortage of ways to get involved right
now
okay uh that's that was my only question
thank you david all right ryan let let
us know if you get involved in something
okay
okay all right ryan from el paso i have
to tell you
upper management written all over them
from what i'm hearing 13 years old
getting involved i love it
one of our sponsors purevpn is giving
you 47
off a one-year plan which comes out to
less than six bucks a month
purevpn makes you anonymous online and
you can trust them they're the only vpn
with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity is not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week
for just 99 cents and you'll get 47
percent off a one-year plan
which is less than six bucks a month
when you go to davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman